being cast in a movie doesn't guarantee
that your name will be in the final
credits these actors got let go from
projects that were already in production
Dennis Hopper one of the groundbreaking
actors and directors of the 60s and 70s
had a notable niche in the 90s playing
villains and films like speed water
worlds and even Super Mario Brothers
that's why it makes sense that he was
cast as Kristoff the all-powerful TV
producer controlling Truman burbank's
Life In The Truman Show however two days
into filming Kristoff's scenes which
were expected to take around 10 days to
complete Hopper was let go from the film
due to creative differences Hopper said
he had an agreement with producer Scott
Rudin that he'd be fired should his work
be unsatisfactory the performance must
have been extremely underwhelming given
director Peter Weir was described in The
Truman Show DVD extras as extremely
reluctant to ever remove an actor from a
movie finding a replacement was
difficult with production set to shut
down if the role couldn't be filled in
time ultimately though Ed Harris took
the job and earned an Academy Award
nomination for the role the Paddington
movies based on the classic children's
books written by Michael Bond are two of
the most critically acclaimed family
films of the 21st century for a brief
time Paddington 2 even outranked Citizen
Kane as the most universally praised
movie ever on Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
heading into two is incredible
one of the many things that makes this
particular series great is Ben with
Shaw's voice performance as the hyper
polite marmalade loving bear that's why
it's a bit surprising to learn that
Wishaw was a last minute replacement for
the previous voice actor Oscar winner
Colin Firth was attached to voice
Paddington in the first movie all the
way through production with the trailer
even being released while he was still
involved the amicable decision to
replace Firth with Wishaw came during
post-production as reported by
Entertainment Weekly birth set of
display it's been Bittersweet to see
this delightful creature take shape and
come to the sad realization that he
simply doesn't have my voice director
Paul King released a statement saying we
love the voice and we love the bear but
as our young bear came into being we
agreed that the two didn't seem to fit
the 2015 Pixar flop the good dinosaur is
an unusual case where almost the entire
cast of a movie was replaced Midway
through production at the d23 Expo in
2013 a voice cast was announced
featuring Lucas Neff John Lithgow
Francis McDormand Neil Patrick Harris
Judy Greer and Bill Hader The Finnish
film featured none of those actors
except for McDormand who played Mama Ida
why did the cast completely change
because the good dinosaur became an
entirely different movie in the meantime
less than a month after d23 the film's
original director Bob Peterson was
replaced by Pete's own the film was
having story problems so son made
substantial changes including making the
Apatosaurus protagonist Arlo younger and
changing the style to more of a Survival
Story the final cast ended up featuring
The talents of Jeffrey Wright Steve Zahn
Anna Paquin and Sam Elliott given the
the mixed reception from both critics
and general audiences whether these
changes were enough to improve the
struggling production remains a question
that may never be answered the
announcement that Johnny Depp would play
Gellert Grindelwald in the Fantastic
Beasts movie series proved instantly
controversial in 2016 the same year
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them
was released Depp was accused of
domestic abuse toward his thin wife
Amber Heard in a heated divorce trial
with depth portrayal of the villain even
more prominent in 2018's Fantastic
Beasts the crimes of Grindelwald the
controversy continued and author JK
Rowling defended the decision to keep
deaf in the series after losing his
libel case against British tabloid the
sun in 2020 however Depp was ultimately
asked to resign from playing Grindelwald
Depp had already shot one scene for a
Fantastic Beasts the secrets of
Dumbledore when the decision was made
and he was paid his full 16 million
dollar salary for the production win
Mass mix ultimately took over the role
the actor made a conscious choice not to
imitate Depp's interpretation of the
character
Kevin Spacey's firing from all the money
in the world was particularly unusual in
that it happened after filming was
already complete and post-production was
nearly finished Ridley Scott's 2017
drama originally had Kevin Spacey in the
supporting role of J Paul Getty the
real-life billionaire who refused to pay
a ransom after his grandson was
kidnapped how much would you pay to
release your grandson if not 17 million
dollars less than two months before the
film's holiday season release date
Spacey was accused of sexual assault
amidst Rising calls for accountability
in Hollywood in response Scott did
something unprecedented he reshot all of
Spacey scenes with Christopher Plummer
now playing Getty in his place most of
these scenes were shot in the same
locations as the original versions with
a single one requiring green screen and
the digital removal of Spacey from the
original footage plumber's performance
ended up being the most praised aspect
of the film with the then 88 year old
becoming the oldest ever acting nominee
an Academy Award history despite the
accolades for Christopher Plummer very
few major Hollywood Productions have
followed the same path of recasting
actors accused of horrific crimes after
filming is already completed that
doesn't mean it's never happened again
though one of the rare exceptions was
Zack Snyder's 2021 Netflix zombie movie
Army of the Dead Comedian Chris Delia
was originally part of the film but
following a series of sexual misconduct
allegations Snyder re-shot all of
Dalia's scenes with TIG nataro in his
place the reshoots reportedly cost
millions of dollars with producer
Deborah Schneider comparing the cost to
the entire budget of the prequel film
Army of Thieves making the process more
complicated was that nataro had to film
all of her scenes alone in front of a
green screen due to coronavirus
precautions were you never on set with
like Dave Bautista or anybody I've never
met Dave Batiste in my life it seems now
like it was worth the effort Not only
was it the right decision morally but
nataro's character of Marianne Peters
ended up being one of the best-liked
parts of the film
Judy Garland's life was as tragic as her
performances were beloved her physical
and mental health problems left her
unable to participate in a number of
films she was set to star in two of
which had already begun filming before
she got fired the first of these was the
1950 musical Annie Get Your Gun she was
fired over a month into a chaotic
production in which her co-star Howard
Keel was injured from falling off of a
horse and director Busby Berkeley was
let go in the May 10 1949 firing letter
MGM executive LK Sydney blamed Garland
for some of the delays in production
Betty Hutton replaced her in the leading
role of Annie Oakley and Garland parted
ways with MGM the following year years
later 20th Century Fox Executives
claimed that Garland resigned for
personal reasons from 1967's Valley of
the Dolls but Garland claims she was
fired reportedly garland would not come
out of her dressing room for days
resulting in very little usable footage
being shot co-star Patty Duke has said
that Garland was mistreated by director
Mark Robson and rumors circulated about
Garland objecting to the content of the
script Susan Hayward replaced Garland in
the role of Helen Lawson and Valley of
the Dolls ended up being the final film
Garland worked on before her death in
1969. Garland was also replaced on
1949's the Barclays of Broadway in
1951's Royal Wedding but those had not
already begun filming when her roles got
recast